aber es ist nicht so einfach jetzt von
dem thema zum thema ehrenmord zu gehen
übrigens ein begriff der sehr
problematisiert in den letzten jahren
wenn man gerne von vier mit spricht aber
wir haben den letzten zwei wochen zwei
frauen isra und schülern die auf
deutschem boden hier in deutschland
ermordet wurden weil sie emanzipiert
leben wollten weil sie von ihrem
selbstbestimmtes leben gebrauch machen
wollen und diese frauen nehmen wir oder
nehmen vor allem die neue feministischen
akteure in diesem land als
kollateralschaden sie wollen sich damit
nicht beschäftigen sie wollen von 14
sprechender trifft ja aller kulturen
aber die kulturellen religiösen
hintergründe solche daten übrigens da
sind nicht nur frauen betroffen sondern
auch männer auch homosexuelle männer
werden ermordet wenn sie in diesen
kulturen homosexualität offen leben das
heißt passt nicht und ich frage mich
warum sind wir nicht mehr in der lage
über bestimmte themen zu sprechen und
diese frauen komplett vergessen es gibt
keine aufschreit keine debatten viele
zeitungen haben nicht mal darüber
geschrieben über solchen phänomen ist
als 2010 haben wir durchschnittlich
übrigens die statistik gibt es nicht es
gibt nur ehrenamtler die so viele
sammeln wir reden von zehn bis zwölf
frauen die jedes jahr in deutschland
ermordet wurden frauen die nach
deutschland gekommen sind weil sie hier
frei leben sollen und sie haben oder sie
sind hier in deutschland ermordet wurden
von ihren familienmitgliedern und
darüber redet keiner und ich sage wer
feministisch sein will wer über
frauenrechte reden will darf nicht auf
einem auge blind sein muss und er da vor
allen dingen nicht glauben dass er für
gleichberechtigung sorgt wenn man für
gender sternchen doppelpunkt sich
verkämpft und auf die straße geht mir
auch briefe schreibt wenn ich nicht
verbraucherinnen sage und das heißt ich
sei gegen gegen frauenrechte was ist
totaler quatsch ist frauen dem nicht so
leben können wie sie wollen nicht leben
können und heiraten könnten beruf
ergreifen können wie sie wollen wenn sie
hier in unserem land leben die leiden
darunter dass wir tolerieren dass es an
menschen und geschlechterbilder gibt und
warum trauen wir uns nicht weil einem
sofort entgegen gehalten wird das sei zb
islamophob dass er rassistisch und ich
habe das auch ich habe ein buch
geschrieben über das thema frauenrechte
dass integration niemals funktionieren
wird wenn frauenrechte nicht vollständig
auf aber wie kommt es denn das sage ich
ganz offen dass ich in der illusion lebe
dass es dieses problem in der breite
seit ein paar jahren in deutschland
nicht mehr gibt wir haben früher
intensiv über solche ehren so genannten
so in der mord diskutiert da kannten wir
alle die namen der umgebrachten frauen
und jetzt die die sie erwähnen kennen
wir nicht dass ich das liegt vermutlich
auch wenn ich will nur eine frage spielt
ich will von mir aus gerne ich will nur
eine frage anschließen
das liegt sicher zum teil auch in den
medien die von den morden erfahren aber
nicht über berichten oder nur kleinen
darüber berichten erscheinen aber gibt
es nach ihrer kenntnis
genug anlaufstellen für frauen aus
solchen familien die sich bedroht fühlen
und die ahnen dass irgendetwas passiert
gibt es spezielle beratungsstellen für
muslimische frauen gibt es aber kaum
wissen sie ich habe zwei jahre bei lka
gearbeitet genau als berater zu solchen
themen vor mir saßen über 100 frauen die
solche gefahren gehabt hatten gehabt
haben und wir haben versucht wirklich
diese frauen zu helfen ist es nicht
immer möglich auch die bürokratie spielt
hier eine rolle es kommt darauf an ob
man in berlin bei ein lka-beamter
ankommt der sich auskennt mit dem thema
oder jemand der diese frau zurück in
ihre familie schickt weil er es nicht
versteht welche dimensionen es richtig
seriös und christen es muslimische
frauen sein die die muslimischen frauen
baten um oder chemische verein lka
beamter es gibt auch lka-beamter die
muslime sind die sich ausgaben und ok
ich ausgepowert mehrerau vielleicht
nicht dass männer sind nicht die die
richtige ansprechpartner in solchen
sachen aber sie haben ja eine frage
gestellt vorher wo sind die medien warum
ist das jetzt mittlerweile politisch
inkorrekt über solche themen licht
löschen warum reden wir um nicht mehr
über integration und dazu gehört
natürlich auch die fixe selbstbestimmung
ich sage ich bin erstmal an kommen in
deutschland wenn ich begreife dass eines
selbstbestimmtes leben für meine tochter
keine risiko für mich und meine familie
sondern eine bereicherung und da haben
wir unfassbare nachholbedarf wir sind
nicht da wir reden mittlerweile von
teilhabe weil dadurch die mehrheit
gesellschaft in der verantwortung
gezogen wird aber über die minderheiten
darf man in eine progressive politisch
korrekte orientierter gesellschaft nicht
mehr sprechen und sie waren diejenige
der damals auch ein kritik an die
talkshows gehalten haben dass sie zu
viel über den islam sprechen ja wir
haben als sie ihm kriminalisiert haben
naja ich kann ich war überrascht bin ja
ein muslim und ich war gern in diese
talkshows es geht um den islamismus es
geht um solche phänomene darum ging es
dann immer war mir ganz darum dass man
keine angst verbreitet vor syrern und
anderen will muslime die nach
deutschland sondern dass man sie
aufnimmt aber das war uns lange nicht
verstehen geht es eigentlich darum dass
man eben diese sehr kulturellen
widerspreche also da es gibt einfach
dinge die kulturell völlig
unterschiedlich sind ihnen in
deutschland man darf das nicht
tolerieren